Speaker 1: John Bolton and Michael Cohen
both speculated that Donald Trump likely
moved at least some of the documents the FBI
wanted to a different golf club. And it is now
increasingly looking like that may well be
the case. Did Trump transfer documents to
Bedminster? That's another one of his golf clubs.
Ex FBI official floats the theory. Peter Strzok
had a very interesting tweet thread over the
weekend where he said, Better check Bedminster
on May six Nara emails Trump to say material is
missing and may be at Mar a Lago that we know this
is part of what ultimately led to the raid. On
May 9th, Trump gets on a private plane from Palm
Beach to Bedminster. On video, several boxes are
seen loaded on to the plane. That is indeed true.
You see in this picture, there are boxes being
loaded onto the plane. Okay. But we know the
boxes are boxes. There could be, you know, just
Sudafed in. There could be anything. Peter Strzok
goes on to say, Does the type and brand of box
look familiar? Well, yeah. I mean, it does look
like the exact type of box that is pictured in the
image of Donald Trump's office where the documents
were found. Great visual, says Peter Strzok,
though number one might be too stacked boxes,
meaning nine, not eight boxes. Good example of
harm to national security from waiting to use
Mar-A-Lago classified documents eyed and interview
these folks. Compare their fingerprints to those
on the seized documents and empty folders. And
certainly when you look at this video, you do see
a lot of boxes that look identical to the ones
that were carried out, that were photographed
in Trump's office being carried onto the plane.
That is absolutely true. Now, it is speculative.
This is a speculative case, but it makes perfect
sense. And remember, Trump's own former national
security adviser, Michael Michael Bolton, it
would be like Trump to have Michael Bolton
as is. I think what happened there is Michael
Cohen and John Bolton I it's a portmanteau.
Michael Bolton, the singer John Bolton, Trump's
former national security adviser, said he probably
moved documents elsewhere. Michael Cohen, who
knows Trump well, said he probably has documents
elsewhere. These are likely not all the documents.
Then we find empty folders marked top secret.
And of course, Trump didn't take empty folders.
At some point they had something in them.
And where the documents are remains a question we
don't know for sure. But as we build up a picture
of what took place, we see that the likeliest
scenario, the simplest explanation is that there
are documents elsewhere somewhere, and now it's
a matter of finding them. We'll have the clip I
played of the boxes being loaded. If you're just
listening today, we'll have that clip on our
Instagram. Find us on Instagram at David Pakman
show. If you want to take a look for yourself.